email marketing goes under the umbrella
of inbound marketing email is the
workhorse of marketing however you need
to learn how to use it right and well so
you can actually add value to your users
otherwise you're just another spam in
the inbox now there are ton of platforms
out there that can help you manage your
email marketing most have some basic
free features so you can consider email
marketing as a free marketing channel
you can break email into two main
purposes both engagement and acquisition
email can be used as a way to keep
people engaged whether it's about a new
feature announcement or continue
engaging in your product on the other
hand email is also used by many
ecommerce sites to drive sales and
acquire new customers so what's
important in an email well first you
need to establish a goal and you need to
develop the right messaging for your
audience now based on your knowledge of
your audience and how your positioning
yourself you should know the tone of
voice for your company you should use
the same tone of voice in your social
posts your blog post and in your emails
and just like with the rest of marketing
you should be testing your message and
adapting to what works best for your
audience with email marketing and the
different messaging platforms you're
going to want to make sure you're
tracking some important things like
opens clicks unsubscribes and
click-through rates now depending on the
metric you're optimizing for which is of
course determined by your goal you'll
test different components of the email
for example if your goal is to increase
the open rate then you're going to want
to test your subject line to get more
people to actually open that email if
your overall goal for your email is to
increase sales then the subject line
isn't going to be enough the body of the
email is going to have to drive those
sales so using a clear call to action
and those hooks that really attract your
customers